you know you can't do cpr on somebody in
a restaurant anymore
why
because if you heard them there's too
many lawsuits coming back the other way
so i was at a place the other day
because i was at a place in new orleans
a while back and somebody got cpr'ed
right and i love that kind of [ __ ] dude
you're in the room you have a [ __ ]
exciting yeah you got four [ __ ] fresh
crab appetizers rolling on the table
dude and somebody might die [ __ ] 11
feet away from you dude you know what
i'm saying
bro it's like the ufc and [ __ ] uh
you know it's like the ufc goes to key
west you know what i'm saying it's a
[ __ ] exotic moment it's exciting so
this lady was you know someone going
well and her husband i could tell in a
beat heartbeat the husband wasn't really
interested in saving her you know right
he's like what's going on he kept asking
her like six times and she you know i'm
not good at charades but i can obviously
tell when somebody keeps pointing at
their throat and not being able to
breathe and pointing at like shrimp on
the table and then pointing in their
mouth
he's like what do you want you want me
to order something else you know he's
like just throwing out these like he's
like future like uh
like uh scapegoats or whatever yeah just
things that would make it seem like no
dessert no dessert
he's just
trying to [ __ ] buy his way out of it
with the excuses what do you mean i'm
the problem like he just started saying
things like
getting into a fake argument yeah that
would hold up in court you know yeah so
then this dude this one guy was pretty
jacked up on some uppers bruh and he
worked there at the place dude and he
was kind of like italian but not really
italian but just had done like so much
like probably like lean type of drugs
that lean you out and gotten so much bad
sun that he looked italian you know what
i'm talking about right yeah
the kind of guy looked like he [ __ ]
tried to buy like own a dolphin once
like it like at a in a time share or
something you know like a dude that's
been
you know doing basically doing cocaine a
lot he rolls over bruh and he [ __ ]
he uh first of all this was the craziest
thing i've ever seen he's going to do
the heim like he starts to kind of do it
he can't really get a grip on the lady
takes his shirt off oh my god
he has tattoos oh bro he had and i'm not
joking a huge linda ronstadt on his back
right which is something you don't see
that much no you don't you don't you've
never seen it and pull up a picture of a
linda ross that's not my next beautiful
young oh there it is right there oh
sorry
[Laughter]
she was kind of the thicker uh tiffany
basically of her time she was like a
thick cindy lauper
you know and let's get a picture of her
in this well younger do you have
anything younger
this is basically right before death
there you go that's titty tom ronstadt
right there they used to call her that
boy
which direction is the north bro you
know what i'm saying
there i bet moss grows on the side of
those [ __ ] bro you know what i'm
saying those things are husky bro she
got her hair cut on the set of spinal
tap oh definitely dude she said she got
her hair cut by a slap chop bro she
looks oh my god but anyway this dude
takes his shirt off right
so
now dude i can't eat if some guy who's
high on drugs has his shirt off in the
room right yeah swallow yeah yeah it's
like a it's like a reflux that i have so
he starts going in on this lady and the
shrimp eventually shoots out and bro
nine minutes later they're having
dessert it's crazy how quickly you
forget that you were just about to die
right right but now i go back there this
a year later i'm there at this place
pascal's manali down there in new
orleans and i said yeah i said dude i
remember the last time we were here you
guys had the little you know it's kind
of like vegas and they do a little show
out front you know right i was like you
guys had that choking you know and uh
and he said yeah we can't do cpr anymore
because it's just too dangerous so if
somebody's dying you just have to like
be there for you just clap
i guess just try to like cheer them on
and like at least go like
go go go yeah just send them more more
more you're
faster faster faster
i wonder if that guy was a deal breaker
fill her up take it to the top
it's like [ __ ] food jenga
[Laughter]
yeah just keep putting it in her mouth
just make her a [ __ ] pinata yeah
yeah
good lord and a shooter open with a
rifle
that's perfect but that shirt dude
definitely had to have something to do
with it well you could tell it's hard to
do the hammock i think in his shirt and
the man was real lean so i think he was
getting he was getting lost inside of
the shirt i like that he committed to it
oh dude he went he went hard man and
after that he had to go take a break he
said he'd been through too much for that
night and clocked out
good lord what it's just like
unbreakable yeah he's just like a hero
amongst us well that's eating in new
orleans man i mean it was [ __ ] crazy
bro
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one